ot not what either Stefano she wrote was
either some caution pop but even he
knows not not either that was many fact
Holly Montana's first
all right
boss a movie
[Music]
[Music]
Salam alaikum guys again we're
continuing our trip in Spain Valencia
and I met Andrews Andrews Andrew Andrew
Andrew iniki's Angela in English Andrew
yeah in English and revenge in Spanish
Andres hundreds hundreds
you've been Muslim three years three
years three years three years that you
say three years three years numb three
years and three months
masha'Allah congratulations why did you
accept Islam because I I and I was 18
years old and one friend say I mean
the Quran is this and this and this and
I I think I thought it is a good a good
religious religion but it is the time of
Ramadan and I listened I thought maybe I
I will have Ramadan and I I have
Ramadan through eight years one week one
week and I feel a good good sensation
sentiment and I think maybe the de
Ramadan and the Islam is a good thing
after after that I I read I read the the
Holy Quran and I I feel that oh he is
the true Messiah you need directly only
only two weeks alhamdulillah and only
alhamdulillah I feel the top head and
the Quran is the true
you said the toe heat free those I don't
know so here is the pure monotheism
that's to complete the unique oneness of
the Almighty Creator so this is what
attracted you to Islam the toe heel now
how do you say toe heel in Spanish how
do you say that in your language the
translation is monitor is mo monitor is
Maputo
the poor monitor is me in Spanish we
said monotheist Maputo what religion
were you before Islam I was
I have eight brothers the umbrella holds
all my family a Christian Christianity
alhamdulillah my family no no I like
with a lot of a lot of Spanish people
[Music]
speak I am Christian but you they are
not Christian practicing practicing okay
so they say say Christian but that
doesn't really practicing now okay these
bad my family is practice so your friend
your practice your family's practicing
now now okay I get it so some say they
were Christian but they're not practice
your family was practice yes Christian
okay so they're practicing Christians
not yeah and I
I have in the past I have the thing I
think God is true God is true I don't I
don't have to do this shock but I feel I
feel when when I read the Holy Quran is
impossible there are I think better of
the time but I've before this I I was I
was a Christian would I
went to the Ganesa to the Iglesia
to the church at the church I I was to
the church i raided the the injeel
they beat the bible and a hungry land my
family say me a good good work
alhamdulillah but Islam for me is so so
better so so but it's more more more
directed and in Islam that our Dalia
there are evidences proofs groups and I
think but it is my opinion and my family
is Christianity but I think that in the
in the Bible there are contradiction
hundred in the Quran in the Holy Quran
there are not traditional there are no
contradictions God Almighty is saying in
the quran that do they not consider the
quran' with care that if there had been
any credit contradiction discrepancies
in the quran go ahead it's a challenge
find it but like you're saying right now
there is none now so this convinced you
now that indeed the Quran is from the
Creator we say Allah how do you say in
Spanish Dios Dios God is
and God these deals in Spanish God is
deal ojala orphan ah you say many
Spanish people say oh holla
is that all allah allahumma hello that's
like saying hello home now that can even
how do you start and see many people
they'll they'll pick up on imagine
you're living during the time of Jesus
Jesus peace be upon him he spoke Aramaic
now we heard you say a few words in
Arabic you're not Arab are you and out
of the know you're learning some Arabic
mmm in out of each no you're saying Arab
you said yourself a lot higher and say
so now that that's one of the miracles
is that the Quran is revealed in the
original language so now that's how it's
been preserved and you start learning
these different words you start reading
that you're reading actually I can tell
right now already you're studying the
Quran is Arabic yes no I read it in
Spanish you read it in Spanish but
you're starting to pick up on some words
you said now now now you're saying some
smell something now I speak you out of
your learning everything a lot of hungry
I speaking Arabic you needed great what
advice do you have for the other Spanish
people so we're in Spain for others who
are now seeking purpose purpose of life
they want to know why they've been
created tell them in English then you
can tell them in Spanish you know what
advice do you have for people they fear
Islam they don't know Islam they think
you know all sorts of crazy things what
advice do you have
I can't speak any pin a Spanish first
given given couple words in English and
in Spanish okay my advice for the people
is that not our opinion without
information I don't know if I speaking I
got you don't form an opinion now
without the right information get the
right information about Islam not from
the media that I say okay now you want
to say in Spanish lo que está diciendo
la hermana es que me consejos para la
gente con la mouche in minato Avia es
que no se puede crear una opinion
si no tiene información probiem NT
and one last thing are there a lot of
people because Islam has such a rich
history for over what seven eight
hundred years now
Islam is predominantly a Muslim majority
and science inventions you know
everybody you know Jews and Christians
were sending their children here to
learn you know people were coming here
for the knowledge while everybody was in
the Dark Ages right
so how are the people now receptive are
there more people coming back to their
to their roots of Islam here now it is
true it is true
well hamdulillah now uni there are a lot
of people come back to the to the Islam
chandelier and Alejandrina in in Spain
the pass al-andalus and Allah and Allah
there are a lot of science knowledge so
shangela from Villa we we must think
about this yeah we must and that that's
that's what we got to do it you care you
share and if you should what you should
care about the people then you should
share and do your part and get out there
and make sure you're the best example
and look at subhanAllah I'm in Spain and
I'm finally a Spaniard you call Spaniard
if you're Spanish you're Spaniard right
Nam yes
Muslim now what I see and what and
simply what's the Muslim one who has
submitted his or her will to the creator
that happens in Arab Jesus submitters
his will to God Moses did Abraham they
all were Muslim and the last and final
message of problem Ahamed peace and
blessings be upon him we'll see you next
time here on the Deen show peace be with
you from Spain so long
you